[Music]
[Applause]
piano I was still back of this very good
Italian I don't every time I run this
game but I read even a target Italia
Italia Alain de menthe annoyed at starve
it's annoying
squeeze my hat all right oh whatever
this is no it's not good so we're gonna
go here and the washing dry or I like
your city things and we got to pull this
bad shot it's gonna happen oh [ __ ] it's
so dark okay is this a good really
[ __ ] easy
Wow maybe they can see me if I had a
flashlight
huh okay let's just [ __ ] kill him
that yes yes okay okay
are you dead bra no [ __ ] I'm so screwed
everybody's didn't [ __ ] run for it
I'm psyched I'm psyched I'm psyched
psyched back okay let's just think is
this wrong like a [ __ ]
honestly okay
okay okay okay I got this Ronald like a
[ __ ]
stop top hook it's yeah [ __ ] move
brah huh no [ __ ] whoa go go oh forget it
forget it oh wow let go Nyko bout that
go back that cool bra night Oh brah I'm
going I'm going I'm going go to either
say buy a kit get perfect [ __ ]
excellent we're good
I don't remember what I was supposed to
go though that's kind of a problem
wait electricity something pet okay
perfect whyever the way the [ __ ] am i oh
all right come on brah
Super Mario at Oh
let me just think I'm gonna run I'm
running here I run here here I guess
here along it's myself [ __ ] well your
sanity electricity thing okay okay I got
it I got it
we can do it boss we can break you if I
can do it okay
thank you
okay okay we're good
[Music]
[Applause]
look
move move move mother we're back okay
we're good go way back
[Applause]
you know ya fix on your buddy
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
how am I going each color I can't see
the graphics are so horrible each caller
/but them for each door what
what I did oh no no not it's not good
friend of alright that I mean I want to
say the game because I I feel safe or
quite safe the game
here's a map
okay orange door I guess I can't leave
so that's not good okay I can go ahead
yeah yeah okay ah don't die on me Brian
I guess we're gonna go here
this is spine where the [ __ ]
[Applause]
Oh can I kill them I have some that say
there's so much damage holy [ __ ] ah wow
that Cobra oh look okay okay okay
we're good I click the orange one right
yeah I don't even know where it is they
just showed me something come on glass
huh what okay good weekend we're again
wait why am I going here
[Applause]
wait there's something here right
alright let's go here huh
[ __ ] I'm out of battery soon okay
can I go here this guy with Super Mario
adding today
you [ __ ] tease I hate you okay
Oh perfect perfect
okay
come on go brah I don't even know where
I guess here and then find the Ornish
room this is it oh yes
there's orange isn't it no it's not
orange [ __ ] I guess is this alright but
[ __ ] okay let's [ __ ] ignore him Oh
[Music]
up
ah
that finish up tup tup tup tup tup tup
tup tup tup tup tup tup tup tup okay
bring it [ __ ] huh I was kidding
okay okay huh
run run run run run oh [ __ ] how am I
even [ __ ] going why am I going here
Oh brah I'm sorry
I like doors okay good okay bro I need
your help like I don't know like leave a
comment telling me what I'm supposed to
go because I really like and favorite
and all I can stuff and I'll see you
soon
[Music]
oh man that's so [ __ ] creepy